abandoning their homes and heading for
dry land the flood waters Rose quickly
forcing thousands of people to leave
nearly everything behind within three
hours the whole place was flooded and it
entered the rooms four bedroom we've
abandoned everything so we had to look
for a shelter and also get a place to
stay the best thing I can do is to move
out and evacuate into a different place
and when the thing comes down then we
just come back for the rest of the stuff
but most of the properties
is damaged
unusually heavy rains cause rivers to
burst their Banks making things worse
two dams further Upstream in neighboring
Burkina Faso were also overwhelmed
normally the rains come in June July and
by this time it is subsiding but because
of the issues of climate change
the weather patterns somehow has changed
Ghana's own dams are under pressure too
and if water isn't released periodically
it could lead to an even greater
disaster
if we do not spill
we rather put the people Downstream in
danger
because
um
we are then compromising on the
Integrity of the town
if we do not handle the world and then
we experience a damp week
the consequences and the repercussions
will be more dying will be more terrible
than we're experiencing them
some of these people are heading to
camps others are staying with family
for now they have little choice but to
wait until the water subsides Benton
Monaghan Al Jazeera